[Applause]
a decade ago
after a peaceful revolution toppled the
long-time tunisian dictator ben ali
i was sitting in an orange grove outside
of athens greece
undocumented migrants were hiding there
i came to interview them about human
rights abuses they had suffered
while entering europe one of them a
tunisian fellow in a leather jacket
explained the people who overthrew ben
ali
they want democracy and a dignified life
we would cross the mediterranean
want democracy in a dignified life what
is the difference
the migrant is a kind of revolutionary
this idea stuck with me
and informed my work as a lawyer and a
scholar ever since
as middle eastern revolutions turned
into civil wars
the refugee crisis unfolded in the
mediterranean
this exacerbated political pressures
against asylum seekers
initially the european court of human
rights took a strong stand against
border violence
in 2012 the court decided that italy
cannot
turn asylum seekers back from the
mediterranean dangerous libyan territory
without first hearing them
the human rights community cheered i was
not one of those who cheered
in my scholarship i predicted that this
kind of decision could also generate
bad results states determined to enforce
their own borders would turn back asylum
seekers even before they enter the
supervision of their own courts
i was regretfully correct in recent
years
the italians have relied on libyan
militias to do their dirty work
so eager are some european governments
to dodge their own human rights
obligations
they have equipped and armed libyan
militia ignoring their rampant use of
torture this is also why
since january 2014 more than 34
000 migrants have died by drowning in
the mediterranean
and since covet 19 began the militarized
border in the mediterranean has become
in some ways even more extreme
but how does a militarized border cause
deaths by drowning
i'd like to illustrate my reference to a
case i'm currently working on
on november 6 2017 a group of asylum
seekers
left the libyan coast and travel through
the mediterranean
hoping to reach europe as the
overcrowded boat
started to break down they sent a
distress signal
and under international law states are
obligated to facilitate the rescue
vessels in distress
now a strange confrontation followed two
vessels
not one came to pick up the asylum
seekers in distress
one of them was sailing under european
flag its crew and civilian clothing
the other was a libyan vessel its crew
armed and in the very uniform of the
government that these people had fled
[Music]
for the asylum seekers the choice was
clear many jumped into the water
determined at all costs not to let the
libyans pick them up
20 people drowned victims of a
contemporary struggle for liberation
across
borders what i didn't predict a few
years back was the courageous response
of civil society volunteers
such as members of sea watch who've
literally inserted their bodies between
the libyan forces
and the migrants in the water crucially
they've also brought back images
from cameras on board and body cams
these images allowed my colleagues
charles heller and lorenzo pizzani to
visually reconstruct the events of
november 2017.
when they came to my team and me asking
that we go back to the european port of
human rights i was hesitant
states always have ways to circumvent
progressive human rights decisions
but the evidence spoke for itself with
my colleagues bayeleta moreno locks and
laura donalo
we filed the case at the european court
of human rights
we argue that italy as well as europe
cannot rely on libyan militia
decides to have their own accountability
on a high level of generality
the question is when is a point of
contact established between a person
in need of protection and a state that
can protect them
i've called this moment the human rights
encounter it is a dramatic moment in
which legal commitments
are put to an existential test it's not
about human rights law generally
but a particular person in a particular
time
about simple commitments we have to each
other
as persons it is not merely by chance
that the sea becomes the environment for
this large-scale struggle for liberation
across
borders as for the court it has
recognized the human rights encounter
when it's physical
and direct in the case i just told you
about we go further
even when mediated by technology or by
proxy forces
the underlying commitments to human
rights should not change
in my organization the global legal
action network
we pursue this case i told you about as
part of a strategic litigation program
we consider international law and the
laws of many countries
we collaborate with researchers and
activists who use
cutting-edge technologies to document
violations across
many borders as war persecution and
climate change continue
we believe the strategy will redefine
the future of human rights lawyer
the future of human rights lawyering is
not only about
a struggle against one corrupt leader or
another
it's also about questions concerning how
do we all
inhabit this planet together thank you